[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in ed werder who covers the
cowboys espn nfl reporter what's your
reaction to that ed
yeah i think uh good morning dan i think
um you know as dak prescott once said
the cowboys were probably guilty of
sniffing themselves
going into this game i mean i think they
had every right to feel
confident they were
playing at home they had a six-game
winning streak
dak prescott was returning they were
averaging 40 points a game at home you
know they're playing a broncos team
that's lost four out of five
they hadn't had a single win against a
quality opponent all year
and
you know they're coming off a week in
which they're going through the upheaval
of wondering if the front office threw
their season away because
the new gm there george payton traded
von miller the greatest defensive player
in franchise history and so there were
all kinds of questions about the broncos
and very few
about the cowboys and then jack prescott
came out and had one of the worst games
of his career his completion percentage
was
um
the he came in as leading the nfl in
completion percentage this was the
lowest completion percentage game he'd
had since he was a rookie against the
giants
in a game that ended an 11-game winning
streak and what he did yesterday ended a
six-game winning streak
you know sometimes we look at a loss and
it's a standalone loss but are there
things there and you're playing in an
easy division or an easier division and
i don't know if there's that there's no
sense of urgency here but is this an
aberration or do you think there's
something a little more to this
yeah i think i think until proven
otherwise it's an aberration but they
still have to prove that this is a
standalone
bad performance and ugly loss it's up to
them to to demonstrate that we reserve
the right to
reevaluate and change our opinion right
now i still think i went into the game
thinking the cowboys are one of the best
teams in the nfc
i still think they're one of the best
teams in the league but if they go do
this this weekend against the falcons in
a game that's going to mean an awful lot
to their defensive coordinator dan quinn
who got fired there last year as a head
coach uh then i might have a different
opinion as to what this team's capable
of but right now i still think they're a
legitimate super bowl contender when did
you realize it was not going to be
dallas this day
well i thought it was an odd decision
you know we've seen mike mccarthy follow
the analytics and be very averse to
field goals and he didn't take one on
either their first two possessions
uh which the broncos interpreted as they
took offense to it they thought it was
arrogance on the on the part of the
cowboys and you know teddy bridgewater
and all the other players that you spoke
to after the game made the same point
that that motivated us we were we were
pretty upset by that uh and they did
score 10 points immediately after the
cowboys failed on fourth down what four
different times in the game the most in
in 20 years that uh they took that
chance sometimes they were forced into
it but i you know i just think it was a
bad day from and there were a lot of
weird things that happened in the game
to their detriment i mean they start the
game with a 54-yard kickoff
turn by tony pollard so they have uh
they're on the broncos side of the field
to start the game and they don't score
with it and you know then they get an
interception by jordan lewis that's
negated by a trayvon diggs penalty
and then they have the block kick to
start the second half in the broncos end
of the field and they don't get the ball
uh in a situation that almost never
happens i mean the rookie nashon wright
is kind of the modern day uh leon let
for for touching a ball that could have
been the cowboys if they just let it low
um and and you can't really expect a
rookie to know that and make that
decision when the ball bounces up in his
face he doesn't know where he is
relative to the line of scrimmage i
totally get that but uh that was just a
you know a confluence of odd things that
happened uh and they didn't benefit from
any of them and so you kind of got the
sense it was that kind of day i would
say relative to the the bite you play to
open up the press conference you know
dak prescott he said something similar
in that you know hey sometimes you come
off a win like we had in minnesota with
your backup quarterback you think you
could just roll out there and get it
done
um and so i think that tells you
everything about the level of
overconfidence that they had and you
know it seemed to me
they cared a lot more about playing well
at the in the last five minutes when
they were trying to avoid the shutout
than they did when they were in the
previous 55 minutes when they might have
been trying to win the game
can dallas out coach other teams
i don't know i think you know i think
mike mccarthy
is questionable in terms of some of the
decisions he makes in terms of game
management i think you know kellen moore
the offensive coordinators demonstrated
that he's a really creative play caller
and knows how to use their personnel and
create favorable matchups and same for
dan quinn you know i think he's taken
the worst defense in franchise history
and turned it into something really at
least average kind of the kansas city
chiefs philosophy when you know they
were been winning the last three years
be great on offense be average on
defense take the ball away create some
short deals and extra possessions which
which brings me to this point dan you
know they went they had 10 straight
games where they created multiple
turnovers
in the last two weeks they've created no
turnovers on defense and they scored 20
points one week and 16 points the next
week
where do you think the cowboys rank in
the nfc hierarchy
i tend to think they're probably not as
good as the rams
and
they'll get to play the cardinals so
we'll see that match up there i don't
think they're probably as good as the
cardinals i covered the cardinals at
tennessee and i thought they were really
impressive in the best game i'd seen
tyler murray play live
uh i think they're probably you know
somewhere around where the packers are
they're probably third or fourth
but one one interesting thing you know
you talked about this bn aberration and
again i think it is the one interesting
thing to watch is
the fact that vic fangio and brandon
staley the chargers first year head
coach they coached together on defense
in denver
um until staley got the job
and they have a shared defensive
philosophy
and yesterday
fangio said
i just don't think a lot of teams played
the cowboys the right way
and so that bears watching from the
standpoint of the cowboys won when they
played the chargers at san diego or at
los angeles in the second week of the
season but they only scored 20 points
that was the fewest points they'd scored
in any dak prescott start and then
yesterday facing many of the same
defensive challenges from fangio they
only short 16 points so maybe there is
something of a blueprint out there dak
when asked about it after the game said
i hope everybody you know plays us the
way these two teams have played us but
the the facts speak for themselves they
didn't handle you know the coverages
being disguised they didn't get blitzed
they they make a living off getting
blitzed and making big plays they took
that away from the cowboys and again dak
had a really bad day throwing the
football and he didn't get help from his
receivers who dropped a lot of pass so
what is that blueprint
the blueprint is play uh
two high safeties
uh change the look at the right in the
previous when he's making his pre-snap
read at the line of scrimmage uh get
four man pressure don't blitz the the
broncos blitz was the fewest blitzes
that dak had seen all year you've been
one of the most blitz quarterbacks in
the nfl uh so get pressure with with
four
and disguise coverages play coverage
that and take away the big play that
seems to be what the chargers
who had success even though they lost
the game and what victangio did
yesterday great to talk to you as always
ed thank you
thanks for the invite dan clean the desk
will you no no never adding more
tchotchkes here not less
that's ed werder espn nfl reporter
covering the cowboys